all right so hopefully you can see
everything have to realize how many
holes in a polo it's not polo the game
right how many polls in a polo
let's try this oh it was right gonna
match box
nobody can can oh yeah
strike the cab noise to it
oh okay okay okay backwards and I'll
answer this question backward okay click
the answer up good thing I randomly
mouse over the answer I can't go left to
right
can't go can't go under
hide the mouse sensitivity guide it oh
I'm running into the keyboard [ __ ]
bastard that was stupid
the answer is really big
this answer is really big right there
it's like fold it out I'm gonna go with
the blatantly what you think is obvious
but I think it's gonna be wrong damn it
sir
look it's a max Albert and they're just
mocking people looking no chance X x
marks the spot up on a sad face
no where where is the answer no way I'm
searching up look at that guy that's how
I feel when I play towards your camper
this is exactly how I feel
are you high is it this at the dot but
is it not this red dot what your will
eat yeah
all right there okay oh no with your
heart go with your heart
but why didn't you tell me to go with my
logic my logic was I bet you is that top
right one because it's spun all the way
around I'm sorry this is at my Lodge
obviously because it's pointing to that
one that one means that one so that one
Eric logic would say it's the freaking
high ball because it's the only thing
that you could actually mean by ball
get why the hell does it choose alright
what follows of them November 2nd the
3rd right Oh what it what follows
December 2nd I don't think like that and
have to that's the game show with what
fall of December 2 so it's just like
this would be the illusion but then this
is probably how can L make the group La
Manga Oleg aloof movie for 120,000 like
oooo i skabble babble they bye-bye buddy
pop Ambridge is saying for Tang I'm
going with the Tang oh thank you
amperage what can you put in the bucket
to make it lighter gypsies obviously not
you
a horse
did a horsey
I bet you somehow it's not okay the last
one was literal
that means it that's right that was the
seventh one what is it that the answer
17
oh I just mouse over it I don't even
know
right
I walk was one skip that's what I want
I would love a plus-one skip
it doesn't give me another water and
give me enough Save Changes 205
grande y Bryn but why brand what the
hell is grand
what does brand have to do
what the hell is to be in the
what
understand
let the only letter hate it but that's
how you kill a werewolf you use silver
bullets do you none this game silly bang
which of these plays
doesn't exist
[ __ ] field even though hey because I
know it's probably exists know what why
what exists this sounded wrong I hope
you've been paying attention to the
question number
odd years
it's either 2426
what is this I don't know a cupcake
ballerina a fairy cake a ballet bun
abundance cruel abundance Oh a fun dance
what flavor is cardboard
I'm not a hobo I don't know this stuff
why my egg mayonnaise no idea there's
nothing to click right
whoa-oh-oh what was that I supposed to
get them in in there
what is it
what is
let's look into it what is it thing ten
arms
I don't know because the other answers
are just as stupid so I was thinking a
really dumb answer I'm here right now
that's what I wanted to pick the part
how is that a cylindrical adventure a
wing rest hello LOL boni 30 rekt Oh
magnificent what it what is it is the
answer fuzzy green is that how it works
but their focus what is this mallards
arse
you're like feel like it has to be one
of the green ones or am I supposed to be
understanding something that I'm not
son of a [ __ ] son of a [ __ ] super
thing
damnit
everything's oh yeah I gotta make the
buzzer
I am cooking here
whatever
oh my god it's the smallest circle ever
what is this I don't read I don't read
in symbol why the green dude or the blue
dude
I click faster you know why I'm what is
the digesta so I Syrians designed to
break food down energy damn it your
laser fire what do you mean I lost both
my life to that I lost both my lives to
that thing come on come on come on
Conklin how much do you need a charge
bro oh yeah be honest did you manage to
do the last question on your first couch
say no but when I would click win I
would click win that's what I would
click ding tasteless white filth
thank you for watching that that was the
impossible quiz that was a terrible
terrible game I hope you had fun
watching it but anyways I want to tell
you guys that this is the last episode
of torture chamber at least for this
season don't worry I'm still around
doing stuff behind the scenes with Dan
I'll be in the chat a lot of cool stuffs
coming up like we've been telling you
we've been hyping it up for the last
couple weeks there's gonna be a lot of
stuff coming February it's gonna be
sorry so you know make sure you stay
with us we're probably still going to do
other like livestream stuff in the next
two weeks until then so check out the
highlights later you can still find me
on the twitch at ey ta Y that's max
Hobart thank you for I guess giving me
some hints follow the twitch channel
also follow us on acting spot on Twitter
to find out whenever we're doing
anything cool other than streaming or
and or if we're streaming but uh thank
you guys so much